hey what is up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
tutorial and uh before i get into this
tutorial i just have a small
announcement uh one thing is that the
link is in the in the description for
this background and number two i was
denied for a youtube partnership for a
lack of insuffic an insufficient amount
of original content
which was you know kind of so so with me
i'm going to try to get back to them on
that but anyway this is going to be a
tutorial on uh the the firefox add-on
that i found one of my favorite firefox
add-ons actually uh called fission and
uh it basically makes your firefox
loading bar if i can open up a new tab
here makes this part up here load and
look like safari 3.0 or 3.2 so let's go
ahead and open up youtube and you'll be
able to see it go ahead and move across
the screen there you go it was actually
very quick
but i'm just going to go ahead and show
you uh this add-on i have the link right
here uh to the actual add to firefox
add-on
the actual link to this page right here
in the description so if you go ahead
and click on that in firefox and hit add
to firefox there's not a whole lot of
steps after that to get the add-on so
basically yeah it's a it's a progress
bar that you can use for firefox and
once you add it like i said it'll look
almost exactly like safari 3.0 now if we
go to tools and go to add-ons here and
go to the extensions filter and fish in
1.0.9 which is the latest version we can
actually customize a few things about
fishing and this is actually my favorite
part about it uh so you can see the
description progress bar and address bar
go ahead and hit the options button
and uh you go ahead and choose the
progress bar's appearance here so you
can use this color palette right here to
select from a medium variety of colors
which is quite nice
but one thing that i that i found really
nice was that if i if i go ahead and
show you this link right here i will
have this tiny pic png link in the
description this is almost exactly like
the safari 3.2.2 loading bar with a few
exceptions so if you want to go ahead
and use that as your loading bar for
firefox as you can see i have a safari
theme going on here go ahead and hit
that browse button
and actually now before you go that
you're going to have to go to this this
tiny pic link in the description and
open this up in firefox and once you've
done so right click on it and save image
as
and we're going to go ahead and name
that
safari loading bar
and hit save so that has been saved to
our desktop and it'll just go ahead and
scan that png for anything malicious
and once we've saved that to our desktop
we can go ahead and use that as our
loading bar as long as it's on our
computer somewhere so go ahead back into
that add-ons window and hit the browse
button
and find where you just saved that i
happen to save it on my desktop and i
named it so it'll be easy to find there
it is right there double click the png
image and there you go it's right there
you get you get a little preview of it
right there in the preview you hit enter
and you go ahead and exit out and that
is what it will look like from now on
when you load a page so let's go ahead
and open up at one of my websites uh the
website i'm writing for and you saw that
right at the top it looked exactly like
the safari 3.2.2 loading bar so this is
definitely one of my favorite add-ons
for firefox right now i'm using firefox
version 3.5 very nice very smooth
and i really do recommend this add-on
for you guys who are looking for a nice
slick styley a very stylish but a very
cool add-on that um that i really i
really do recommend
so anyway thanks for watching this
tutorial on fishing the firefox add-on
every link that you will need is in the
description and uh please rate this
video as high as you feel like it try to
help me uh get another run at becoming a
youtube partner and that is basically it
thank you for watching peace out